the design of prosthetics offers a great
parable for innovation today consider
for all the invention that surrounded
the knee itself creating new ways of
mimicking the way a human knee moves
there's been relatively little attention
paid to the socket which is the molded
cup that meets the residual limb even
the best molded cup is uncomfortable
where for anything longer than a few
hours one company that we found taking a
really bold look at the problem was limb
well in many cases designers try to put
themselves in the place of the user
let's say you were designing something
for somebody who was blind you might be
able to close your eyes and imagine what
it might be like to be blind but you
can't take your leg off so we built this
rig it's called the empathy rig what it
does is it gives designers who are not
amputees inside around what it's like to
carry your your weight of your body up
under your tailbone we've created a rig
where we can interchange the seat parts
very quickly and understand what feels
more comfortable what's giving support
what's giving control the thigh is meant
to transfer weight down to the foot but
upon losing a limb at the thigh level
you now have a distal stump that is not
accustomed to bearing weight what we're
capable of doing is a almost bicycle
seat type concept or an issue seat we
call it in the traditional socket this
purpose is integrated into an entire
frame with the limb infinite socket
we've essentially isolated that that
functional purpose into one aspect of
our socket and tried to optimize it the
mainframe is based on a thermoplastic
carbon fiber which is selected for the
performance that those materials bring
the carbon fiber struts come as enlarged
sheets and we water cut them to specific
sizes and from a digital file of a
residual limb we capture certain
portions of that surface and create a
digital representation and mold the
carbon fiber to that representation the
limb is dynamic different portions of
the limb also change
on a day-to-day basis residual limbs
fluctuate about 10% volume over an
extended period of time
with the infinite socket we've built in
adjustability to essentially become a
dynamic device we took a lot of
inspiration from the athletic industry
specifically snowboard Bootsy in terms
of how they conformed around the limb
especially the ratcheting buckle system
there's a brim at the top which serves
as a soft tissue interface and that has
an adjustability to it these are parts
of the brim internal parts ischial seat
mechanism slides into this portion of
the brim one of the engineering feats
was to we needed tension here and at the
top figured out a little triangulation
so this outside broom gets these macro
adjustment buckles which allows us to
tension it the entire thing with one
single ratchet well the first time I put
it on it felt like a shoe or a baseball
glove or something that you would want
to put on every day and I walked all
over San Francisco
companies like Lim offered good proof of
the maxim of the design isn't just about
creating some fancy new objects rather
it's about finding the right problem to
solve and in this case solving that
problem immediately improves a life